The following content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
SAL: Hi.
I'm Sal.
Today we're going to solve
problem number two of test
three of fall 2009.
Now before you attempt the
problem, there are certain
things that you need to know
to solve the problem.
One is mechanical properties
of metal and also the
properties of amorphous metals,
which are known as
metallic glasses, and
how to draw crystal
structures given to you.
The problem reads as follows--
for a given alloy composition,
explain why the yield strength
of the amorphous form, the
metallic glass, is greater
than that of the crystal form.
Now in order to answer this
question, you want to start
thinking about the mechanical
properties that these two raw
materials have. So if I look
at a metal, I know that the
way a metal deforms before it
reaches classic deformation--
it deforms the planes sliding
past one another--
so it's known as slip.
So I know that metals--
they form via slip and slip is
facilitated by dislocations
and you should know what a
dislocation is by now, which
is just a line imperfection
in your crystal.
So slip is facilitated
by dislocations.
So I know that my metal has
planes that are arranged
because it's a nice
crystallographic structure--
and that the slip--
when it undergoes deformation,
that this is actually assisted
by dislocation.
So having dislocations helps
to form our metal.
So now I want to start thinking
about what a metallic
glass has-- so the
amorphous form.
So if I look at the
metallic glass--
and all I'm doing here is
comparing the basic properties
between the two--
so this is going to get
me metallic glass.
I know that for metallic
glass, there's
no long range order.
So the fact that there's no long
range order means that
these metallic glasses don't
form a perfect crystal array.
And that lack leads to metallic
glasses having no
dislocations.
So if a metal slip is
facilitated by dislocations
and if a metallic glass doesn't
have dislocations,
then I would assume, just by
comparison between the two,
that the threshold for one of
the materials to yield would
be due to the fact that--
whether or not I have
dislocations.
So with this argument, I would
say that the metallic glass
has a higher yield strength
than my metal
because of this property.
So that--
if you did that-- if you went
ahead and wrote all that out
for your answer in part A, you
should be able to get most of
the points for this problem.
Now part B--
it asks, on each of the
following separate drawings of
one face of an FCC unit cell--
FCC stands for face
centered cubic--
indicate one of each
of the following.
So now we're going to
move on to part B--
and part B wants--
there's three scenarios.
One--
it wants us to indicate on
a face of a crystal, a
substitutional impurity--
so substitutional impurity.
So if I look at--
if I draw a face--
here.
I can--
so to find out what the
definition of a substitutional
impurity is, I know that it's
not going to be anything that
can be just embedded
in between atoms--
like an interstitial.
I know that it's going to be
a substitutional impurity.
So if this is one of the
faces of your crystal--
and it's FCC, which is face
centered, from the face-- the
face is centered on the center
of an atom on your face.
Then I would say that if I
substitute this out for a
different atom of type B
compared to these atoms, then
that's a substitutional impurity
because that atom is
not the same as the other.
It's like having silver and
gold, for example, in
composition.
And then it also asks
for the second part.
So that's number one.
For number two, it wants us
to demonstrate a vacancy.
Now a vacancy is simply an atom
missing from a normal
lattice site on your
crystal array.
So if I draw again another face,
then I can leave that
blank and I can go ahead and I
can point and I can say that
the vacancy is actually--
sits right here.
So this is my vacancy.
There's no atom that's there.
It moved out of its place.
So that's another defect
that we put in there.
And for three, it asks, an
interstitial impurity.
So what's interstitial?
Well, an atom that can fit in
between two atoms that are
different than the
one that fits.
So if I draw again an FCC face,
I notice that there's
certain spots where an atom of
a different composition can
fit and I can go ahead and
I can just put a--
that's an atom of different
composition and that can very
simply be your interstitial.
So that's your interstitial
impurity.
So knowing the definitions,
you're able to answer this
problem very simply.
There was no math involved in
this and all you needed to
know was knowledge of our
mechanical properties of
metals versus amorphous metals,
which are known as
metallic glasses.
And knowing that information,
you're able to answer a
question like this, which is
pretty simple after you finish
and you think about it.
And if you didn't know
what FCC was--
which stands for face centered
cubic, you could have probably
lost a lot of points
on this problem.
But if you know that, if you
know how to draw it, then
you're good to go.